[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans le débrief des questions au
gouvernement
pour commencer l'image du jour avec un
peu de tendresse dans l'hémicycle ça
n'arrive pas si souvent alors ne boudons
pas notre plaisir je vous laisse
découvrir cet échange entre valérie la
croûte députés les républicains de seine
et marne et le premier ministre edouard
philippe
monsieur le premier ministre c'est non
sans une certaine émotion que je
m'adresse à vous pour la dernière fois
après avoir été élu maire de la très
jolie ville de nemours vous qui avait
siégé sur les bancs de la droite et même
à mes côtés pensez vous que ce nouveau
monde est vraiment à la hauteur des
enjeux colossaux de notre pays
madame la députée nous avons lors de
notre première séance
dans cette thématique siéger côte à côte
un peu plus haut là au fond et je veux
dire madame la députée que quels que
soient les choix que vous et moi avons
fait est que vous et moi
assumons j'ai un souvenir ému et
beaucoup d'affection et de respect
pauvres
vous avez dans votre question madame la
députée coop
j'ai quand même le droit de dire à
madame la députée que pendant cinq ans
nous avons siégé ensemble et que j'en
conserve un excellent souvenir
oui oui vous avez bien entendu c'est
bien le mot auquel vous pensez c'était
en début de séance et cette relative
légèreté s'est ensuite bien vite estompé
pour laisser place au thème du jour le
soutien aux policiers et l'affirmation
de l'ordre républicain et sur ce sujet
la droite de l'hémicycle s'en est donné
à coeur joie
la délinquance frottent les mains
parce que la république se bandent les
yeux vous avez fourni des armes morales
et judiciaires à la voyoucratie alors
une centaine de tchétchènes armes et
déclenché de guerre civile à dijon pas
moins de cinq questions posées sur ce
sujet nous en avons retenu une selle de
maximy nos députés les républicains de
l'oise écoutez oui il nous faut soutenir
nos forces de l'ordre car il n'y a pas
de liberté sans sécurité de même que la
république ne peut exister sans ordre
public
monsieur le premier ministre il ya des
ambiguïtés sémantique qui sont des
lâchetés politique ni si con mais pas et
affirmer sans réserve votre soutien à
celles et ceux qui nous protège vous
avez raison nous devons à nos forces de
sécurité cet engagement et je n'ai
jamais jamais cessé de le porter de
l'incarner et de les défendre et à vous
écouter je n'accepte pas je voulais dit
que l'on insinue que j'aurais pu
abandonner un quelconque moment nos
forces de l'ordre moi j'ai été à chaque
fois présent à leurs côtés quand ils ont
été blessés insulter stigmatiser moi je
moi je moi je répétais en boucle
plusieurs députés pour déconcentrer le
ministre pendant cette intervention
christophe castaner sur la défensive
contraint de justifier certaines de ses
décisions contraint aussi de défendre
certains de ses propos il a été le
ministre le plus sollicité aujourd'hui
dans l'hémicycle voilà pour cette séance
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau débrief des questions au
gouvernement
[Musique]